the most iconic sound in the history of
Esports the op but how has it changed
over the years this is pretty sick this
is very good 1.6 op sound is
it's so mean look at that
it's so thunderous it actually Echoes so
well
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah that's what you need out of an
off sound I think I favor the 1.61 ever
so slightly but 100 it's just because of
nostalgia and because 1.6 is a better
game oh my god oh it's such a good sound
it's such a good sound oh oh it's like
it activates like old memories of of
sick highlights like famous highlights
from the early years of csgo
really loud it's just like it it it
lingers is the word it lingers
which is just like oh it sounds so good